when we're talking about Gene regulation
it's through you have to remember that a
gene is a short segment or short
sequence of DNA and so a gene is a unit
of hereditary
and think of a gene as a trait so any
trait that you might have whether you
are tall whether you have brown eyes
these are all controlled by genes and
the turning on and turning off of these
genes is what gives us our traits so
gene expression is basically the turning
on of that Gene and Gene regulation is
how a Gene gets turned on at a specific
time
for the basis of this uh talk I'll be
talking about eukaryotic Gene
transcription every cell in your body
has the same DNA which means it has the
same genes okay and so when your cells
migrate this is during the development
process when your cells migrate to
certain areas in the embryo it gets
certain cues to turn on a specific gene
or turn off that specific Gene and those
cues then help tell the cell if it's
going to develop into a lung cell if
it's going to develop into a heart cell
if it's going to develop into an eye
cell brain cell muscle cell and so on
and so forth
so the central dogma is you have your
DNA which is then transcribed into your
RNA which is then translated into your
protein
in gene regulation you have your RNA
polymerase which is transcribing the DNA
into an RNA message also known as mRNA
for transcription to initiate it has to
have some sequence or some sight on that
Gene to know where to bind so where
would the polymerase know where to bind
this is where the promoter which is
specific for each gene comes into play
and so once the RNA polymerase sees that
promoter it binds to that promoter and
then it starts the transcription process
of that Gene
so when we have Gene regulation okay we
not only have you know sites on the DNA
that lets the RNA polymerase know where
to bind but you also have different
segments on that Gene called enhancers
and silencers that also affect how that
Gene is turned on or turned off
enhancers are specific segments of DNA
that basically increases the amount of
gene expression that you have or the
rate of gene expression that you have
and then next you have another segment
on that Gene called silencers
it will then turn off or slow down that
rate of gene expression in eukaryotic
Gene regulation there are multiple
levels in where that Gene can be
controlled you have the epigenetic level
which is the higher level up that's on
the DNA itself and then the
transcriptional regulation you can have
the effect on the promoter the effect on
the enhancer the effect of the silencer
okay and then the post transcriptional
regulation how that messenger RNA is
then processed and then you can also
control it at the translational level
and how that protein is actually being
made and then the post-translational
level how that three-dimensional shape
of that protein is being affected
another level in which you know gene
expression can be controlled is through
transcription factors so these
transcription factors which are proteins
okay then can bind to either parts of
the regulatory element in in that
segment of DNA whether it is the
promoter region whether it is the
enhancer region or whether it is the
silencer region so if these
transcription Factor comes in and binds
to the promoter it can either tell the
RNA polymerase hey bind here at a
tighter rate and so that would increase
the rate of transcription or these
transcription factors can bind to the
promoter and block the RNA polymerase
from coming and binding and that goes
the same way with how transcription
factors work with the enhancer portion
these transcription factors when bind to
the enhancer region can even increase
the G gene expression of that Gene even
more okay as well as when these
transcription factors are binding to the
silencing part of that regulatory
element it can silence that Gene even
more
all of that encompasses Gene regulation